we are satisfied and we're live oh we're
live welcome guys back to the weekly
poll convergence SL incursion SL all
neww Comics explained event I am Benny
the comics storan and today I'm going to
I've got no Comics to show you I'm just
going to show off that I have a Majora's
Mask new 3dsxl and make you all
cry that thing was amazing to get I'm
Benny the comic story and that is Rob
the Marvel
dccomics you name it he'll talk about it
explained guy and that is s the TV
little house and today due to our
incursion we are merging with England
and we are having a battle with the
channel known as it's super effective
everyone welcome F to the
show that's I'm always the only one to
CL I'm like
Yay there we go there you thank you here
that way what do you want from me anyway
all right so uh like we normally do with
our with the podcast we want to open up
we're going to give you an opening so
you can talk about your channel we're
going to give you an ending so you talk
about your channel fast um just so
everyone knows fa is a part of the
weekly poll website he has his own
section his own Forum um we did tell him
that the forum's alive 3 days late but
he knows about it now so we're
good um and other than that F why don't
you tell about your channel let everyone
Hi I suck at promoting this but um my
name is f i run the channel at super
effective I do comic book history and
comic book news and explain stuff about
the comic book universe and sometimes
I'm called budget comic book girl 19 and
now of the times I'm not called that
budget comic com
comic budget you need to explain that
one to sim hair yeah you got to explain
that it was literally just a comment the
other day and I was like I like that Tak
that it's going on to the site I'm
budget comic book girl
19 so yeah guys he does the same thing
to the rest of us do we explain comic
books we talk about comic books he goes
more in the direction of like nerdy and
ER where he's got his on camera Persona
and he presents it in a better S tries
to do that too but we all know s's just
[Laughter]
trying oh no you know I love you so so
uh so we were talking about this
beforehand guys we don't have very many
big topics to talk about so we actually
were talking about pre-show about fa
hair yes so F can you explain to us how
you constantly change your hair and why
you constantly change the hair of it
super effective I constantly change my
hair because I get bored very easily and
hair Dy is
cheap but um no when I started YouTube
my hair was a wig because my hair was
damaged from changing it too much and
then I dyed it to red and blue because I
I really liked the Suicide Squad at the
[Laughter]
time a good reason I had this weird sort
of week where I really wanted to be like
have Harley Quinn's hair so I bought the
wig of her pigtails I was like I don't
really wear this out so I got hair like
that and then I got bored of that
eventually and decided I'm going to go
silver and then I cut it all and now
here we
are
sweet there's the story
of guys we'll see you next time right
here great show everybody it's a
lifechanging story that I want them to
make a documentary about um that will
um it will be called f that the ha story
you do you one better hair Chris heav
Chris Evans would play my hair
naturally with Madonna as me nice I say
I the YouTube Avengers make a series of
videos on your hair Benny can do F hair
the complete story s can do like f hair
like off the scalp I guess or something
SC off the scalp I can already see how
it would dramatically read that too I I
could be like you know and then F
decided he needed to dye his hair and it
was a sad day when he dyed it blue and
red but that was only the temporary
until he cut
it has some like dramatic music like
piano music in the backround I could
have like the really sad piano music
that I use like when somebody dies in a
comic
book or if the Hulk is hitchhiking yeah
oh man the sad hitchhiking M so uh okay
I think we've talked enough about eth ha
but there is another we didn't want to
talk about um and that is um with DC's
convergence and we have a few costumes
coming across the board um but this year
seems to be in my opinion the year of
comic book costume changes we have a new
Spiderwoman we have silken I think her
fourth costume since being created like
eight months
ago she's she had like a skin tight
outfit then she had her white and R
black now it's like a black and red and
I don't I don't know now I actually
enjoy her white outfit the white yeah
yeah yeah no no no no the uh the one
that she was wearing during spiderverse
that one where she's naking
no that's creepy but the reason we
wanted to talk about F about this is fa
is a obviously humongous fan of Starfire
he is a fan we all anybody who watches
the videos knows this and I tweeted F
the newest image of Starfire and his
response was oh no not that stupid
Forever 21 stuff he was just seething
I may be paraphrasing there may have
been some cussing some swears in there
he might he might have then direct
messaged me a novel as to why he hates
it I don't
[Laughter]
know so the question is FST why do you
dislike them putting clothing on
Starfire because it's pretty much what
they're doing yeah um well because
before all of our costumes you could see
in like uh like London Fashion Week uh
La Fashion Week Milan Fashion Week all
of our costumes were very clearly um
based off of high fashioned models uh
like even in just pick up an issue of
vog Italia you can very much clearly see
that those swimsuit designs in bog
Italia are kind of like what Starfire
was wearing and now she's looks like
she's dressed like she's gone shopping
with her dad's credit card and she's
like oh my god I've got my Dad's credit
card and Starbucks as test like
that's there
wow I mean like it seems that it's just
part of the new 52 young ification of
characters where like I mean when when
when Star for is initially created for
the for the Teen Titans and kind of like
as a uh like as a love interest for
Robin I mean wasn't she created i f you
were talking about this earlier how she
was kind of created as like a sex symbol
kind of character she was literally
created for sex because Mark wman and
George p
wanted to sort of experiment with the
idea of teenagers having sex because
let's be honest people wait until
they're 18 no yeah oh yeah United States
man like like
here all the time crazy man I'm so far
behind and the Starfire was specifically
created because she was sexy and she
knew it and she could kind of play with
Robin on it and oh
God I'm sex like as I could see that I
mean I remember watching your video
about Starfire and initially she was
created for that and she wasn't aware
like the whole idea of why she was half
naked is it didn't mean the same thing
on her planet right what I'm sorry and
and that was her their excuse well we
can make her butt naked she doesn't know
what she's doing because her people
don't treat it that way you know yeah
it's based on a culture I made up that
is yeah I've completely invented this
culture and by the way in my culture the
men are all enormously buffed dudes and
the women are all Stark naked walking
around no one says anything about it
it's just it's normal yep I have
commitment L sex and it's just totally
awesome I found that like but it's
interesting because as like as as
Starfire became more ingrained in the DC
uh universe and more in the pop culture
angle of it like they tried to make her
more like young and kid-like especially
with the Teen Titans Cartoon like she
became
like the antithesis of her initial
creation like she was pure like pure but
she was innocent and sexless like she
had no understanding whatsoever of
sexuality it seemed wasn't there a few
episodes where like other characters
were attracted to her or like wanting to
try and like oh I I want to go date
Starfire I mean in the kid way it wasn't
like I want to go bone
Starfire would have been a very
different show I want to go play video
games with her you know yeah yeah
exactly no but well even is in their in
their like I I would assume the Teen
Titans in the uh like Cartoon Network
not Teen Titans Go but the one right
before that which I guess was just
called Teen Titans yeah I'm pretty sure
it was just called Teen Titans just the
Teen Titans Cartoon whatever age they
were at I'm assuming they were like 16
15 um in that kind of like you know I
notice girls or or I notice the like I
find people attractive and so I want to
I don't even know what I what I'm doing
with this body but I want to express it
in some way you know so so with that how
you discovered things when you were
younger S I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know what this is happening what
am I gonna do yeah I'm just so
uncomfortable in this th in this
shell internet thank God for that no we
didn't have oh God I mean we kind
discussion for another day but I have I
did see research that apparently most
kids now are learning about everything
like sexuality and everything from the
internet I saw an article question oh
God that's the worst place to learn
about that is it is it really is the
internet really the worst place to learn
about sex or is or is it worse to learn
it from peers who don't know anything
the internet's a worst place to I think
it's the internet buddies fair enough
all right that's what you do wrong I'm
just saying that right now I mean I got
some funny stories that I can't say in
the podcast but well that that'll be
that'll be postp podcast discussion
because I want to hear that I want to
hear those
stories they are not say for work this
conversation going but anyway back to
the topic on H she was made for
sexuality and now they're giving her
more clothes and he said and your reason
is you feel like she she stole her dad's
credit card to go and get the outfit but
don't you feel like after 20 years or so
it's time to change up some of these
costumes I mean bat girls are great
example now she's all hipster and
wearing Doc partens and just weird I
feel like um so every character has
almost a job that they were made
specifically to do and it's kind of how
we justify creating a new character or
using an old character in a title every
character has a job and part of the job
of Starfire's design was to almost be
high fashion um like costumes are a big
thing for me costume is half a character
for me um and to take that aspect away
from Starfire is to take half of what I
loved about Starfire away um so for me
it's sort of who's the for me to see
like of her like that in the comics is
sort of like who is this character I
always Justified it by the Teen Titans
Caron because that wasn't Starfire that
was an archetype with the name Starfire
at the end of the day that's what the
Teen Titans Cartoon was um so so okay
you're so when you first saw show when
you first watch that show number one you
must have been really jazzed that they
were making a Teen Titan show but then
not getting the Starfire that was your
Starfire did you eventually reconcile
that or was it just something where you
were like all right well I'm going to
watch not Starfire and Amazing
Friends uh I always just kind of saw it
as they were archetypes that were made
to sort of make the Teen Titans card
because I was still fairly Young when
that came out but I'd already read most
of the Teen Titans and my like my
parents had no limit I was like three or
four when I first watched Beetle Juice
so so I don't know I just always saw it
as they just didn't do the characters
from the comics because they weren't
kid-friendly and they wanted the cartoon
to be kid-friendly and the comics
weren't made for the audience that they
made the show for which at the end of
the day raises the question why adapt
the comics when they clearly didn't want
to adapt the comics but that's the whole
other thing well I mean they're just
going for recognizable characters I mean
all honesty I mean the flash is pretty
close but Arrow I mean I know I know you
mentioned before this that you don't
like watching Arrow and Flash half our
audience just like unsubscribed from
your channel
so it's okay my audience no I don't like
it but um Arrow I mean flash is pretty
close to the comic they've done a couple
tweaks in here and there but arrow is
completely separate from it but it's
it's same concept of you know oh
everyone knows Green Arrow from back in
the day and they all remember him from
Smallville he was the cool guy in the
hoodie you know so let's make a dark and
bring Batman version that's not by the
way the same character right they didn't
tie it in with no no I know initially
when the initial discussion started
supposedly that was where they were
going with it like they were I from I
don't know if this is rumor or not when
Arrow first started they were in talks
with that guy to just continue the role
and just continue the show that's cool
but then everyone was like well we don't
want Smallville again and you can't get
away from that if you take over the
whole same cast and everything
yeah interesting but but anyway yeah
just like the Teen Titan show I mean
it's I mean that's why they in my
opinion they do it because they're going
for recognizable characters I mean why
why else would the new 52 launch with
all your same superheroes in a totally
different manner
yeah super I feel like at least with
this costume change and while it might
not represent what Starfire used to
represent or what should represent now
um at least they're thinking about it as
opposed to for me like the new 52
relaunch when it first started and they
had the new costume changes where they
they all have the same I mean they still
do with their little collars and their
little piping and their you know
underwearless and it was just kind of
like a okay well just make them all the
same like make them all uniform and I
think what was it I I think that giving
Jim Lee Andor George Perez the the the
the keys to the family car with costume
design was kind of like a AK cuz they're
going to draw things that they feel
comfortable with which is not
necessarily good for like the
iconography of these characters like I
don't know just felt like the new 52
redesign was kind of like a oh draw the
qu we like everything just feels like
well since flash point they were like oh
we got to get the all our ducks in a row
and also we're redesigning all the
costumes so make sure that happens too
like at least now they're like okay like
with the bat girl R design sure it's a
35-year-old dressed like a like a
14-year-old um
if they just had taken a freaking minute
and said hey uh let's make Barbara
Gordon 19 and just say that that's how
it is now because flasho people will buy
it because they they buy
everything uh but at least you know even
though they didn't do that at least they
had the time to go like okay like let's
actually change the costume in kind of
an interesting and meaningful way I I
mean like I'm one of the few people who
really likes that barbar Gordon costume
I think it's weird for a 3 5-year-old to
dress like that that's my complaint with
it like and I mean I I don't I actually
like the new costume myself for bobber
Gordon and I know I know you're gonna
You're Gonna Hate Me F but I actually
like the Starfire costume that feels
kind of time to update her you know I
also will argue that I kind of dig the
new Starfire costume too but then again
I love anything Amanda Connor draws so
it could just I could be biased it could
if you give it to somebody else I'm sure
it'll look like garbage um that said you
I'm looking at the creative team for
Starfire number one and it's I me an
Conor and jimmmy palotti writing it and
I'm not the biggest fan of what they're
doing with Harley Quinn
so well I would kind of agree because I
loved Harley Quinn when it started I
yeah uh I really really loved it and for
like the past two months it just kind of
been I liked the Christmas special but
then the actual Christmas one I was just
a bit like like the actual December one
I was like yeah okay and then January's
one again I was just kind of like yeah
yeah right
I mean not to get too far off topic but
the reason I I I because I agree with
you that f with the Harley Quinn the
problem I have with Harley Quinn is she
has some crazy Adventures like the the
Powergirl one and they're awesome or she
goes and does Harley quinnes things and
then it just feels like they're trying
to interject real life oh and now she
has to go get the rent and go hang out
with her friends and go work at this job
at a roller derby and I don't care about
any of that just go team her up with
another superhero and let her be Harley
Quinn like now wouldn't it be cool if
they did that with the character since
like I feel like DC kind of doesn't
really know what to do with Harley Quinn
but they but they do any like they're
just like we'll do whatever and give it
to am manac Conor and Jimmy palat they
know what they're doing uh wouldn't it
be cool to kind of just make her into a
teamup character like not NE like just
make it a Harley Quinn book but every
issue it's like Harley it's it's like uh
what Batman Robin became after uh Batman
died and it was like they teamed up
different Batman like different
characters like it was Batman and
Catwoman and Batman and Twoface and
Batman and Robin and you know that kind
of thing like I'd actually love to see
that and especially because Harley Quinn
you could have so much fun with the
designs like Harley Quinn and Red Robin
what would her Red Robin costume be or
Harley Quinn and wondergirl would she
wear the old wondergirl costume like
well I kind of wonder if the Harley
Quinn Powergirl comic is going to be
like that like I mean unless they're
going to cuz I don't know what they're
going to do because I I've been
following Earth to and all that other
stuff and Harley Quinn I mean power girl
is pretty much on the way out the door
they pretty much just crapped on every
aspect to the character they've given
her some cool background they've given
her some cool history with her Earth to
you know she's wearing the shield of
Superman now but like I feel like we've
gone as far as we're going to go with
this character at this point like this
is it like you've hit your Peak now you
can die yeah well that doesn't
necessarily mean they're going to kill
her though well technically they already
have because in Futures End she's like
her brain's been taken over by Brother
eye and she's dead everyone's brains
been Tak it over by Brother Rock like we
know that's not going to happen no no no
but no no not not in the future in like
future story I'm talking like the one
that ties directly in with world world's
end and that one she's been taken over
you can tell read to be fair we don't
exactly know where Harley Quinn is set
because one month it's not in Earth 2
then it is in Earth 2 but then power
girl's there but it's still not enough
to so whatever happens to Powergirl
doesn't really affect a Harley Quinn
book no no you're right you're right and
I and but what I'm saying is like the
power girl one I don't I just don't know
what she could do with Harley Quinn at
this point you know they're all getting
these weird redesigns she got a Superman
Shield which is just funny but you know
Harley Quinn's got a new costume every
other week it looks like like I I
personally think it's funny when she
just like it seems like she has three
costumes per issue you know Harley Quinn
now is in her Roller Derby outfit now
she's in here I'm super smart and
hanging out at my giant apartment
building outfit oh and now here's her
adventuring outfit and they have
established where Harley Quinn is she's
not in Gotham did you read the
Valentine's Day issue no didn't they
establish that in the first issue wasn't
she in Rhode Island she's in Rhode
Island
what I'm saying is like they've
established okay not so much that it's
not in batham but that it's still in
main continuity because in the
Valentine's Day issue Batman shows up oh
yeah cool the Valentine's Day issue is
they get they get in a weird having to
go in a date situation it's hilarious
read it if you haven't okay I've I've
been kind of reading it because so
disappointed with last few ones that
particular one is good because Batman
shows up they get stuck having the date
not goingon to spoil what happens but we
do establish it's still in continuity he
explains that towards the end cool I
have to admit the Harley Quinn specials
are really good like the Harley Quinn
Christmas special where she blows up
that car that was
hilarious so yeah okay I mean costume
design so how do you feel about the the
various changes that are going on in the
uh Marvel Universe I don't know how how
familiar familiar you are with the
Marvel Universe I know the rest of us
are but like Spiderwoman is getting a
complete redesign after what like 30
years of skin tightness well they've
changed her every once in a while but
this is like oh no okay okay in Li of
Chang ing Jessica Drew Spiderwoman
costume they just invent a new
Spiderwoman so this first time changed
costume no they haven't s she's been in
that same skin tight outfit 76 or
whatever yeah I like for Spider Woman
with me like and first off no one's
really feeling her new title because
Spiderwoman you're supposed to have her
in like these weird weird adventures and
she is not having that um but I don't
know I'm liking the idea of her new
costume but then my favorite Spiderwoman
run or my favorite Spiderwoman is mattye
Franklin where she had a new costume
every [__] issue
yeah oh man Maddie Franklin that's
taking me back in Friends of the
Spiderwoman comic and I've said this
before I think they gave it a rust start
this next issue is going to be the
official start of Spiderwoman these
first four issues were just nothing but
spider bur Titans which is horrible cuz
it says Spiderwoman number one by the
way did you read all this other crap cuz
if you didn't they don't know what the
hell's going on yeah you don't have no
idea oh also it's drawn by Greg land so
all
right also we have the infamous cover
that was drawn from a naked woman all
right that was I mean I don't understand
why they did that like I don't
understand nothing the chick who was
posing and or I guess drawn from a naked
picture I don't understand why they
decided to launch Spiderwoman number one
tied into spiderverse maybe to be like
well I mean people are going to buy this
so they're going to have to go and buy
the rest of spiderverse no sir
spiderverse I think was absolute garbage
I hated spiderverse and so I'm I'm not
going to go and if I were a Spiderwoman
fan I'm not going to go out and say well
I mean I want to I really really really
want to check out like Jessica Drew solo
Series so you know I'm G to go by all of
spiderverse no that's that's not sales
that's exactly what it is if you look at
the top grossing books of the last five
months it has been in the top three
spiderverse so yeah dropping off why do
you think why do you think they
continued the team up thing cuz I
totally have a feeling that that
spiderverse teamup book wasn't supposed
to continue no cuz after the first two
issues where there was actually good
stories that wrapped into everything the
follow on were just like oh hey check it
out it's a punk Spider-Man you thought
he was cool in the book right yeah I
feel I feel like if they wanted to just
do a spiderverse tie-in for Spiderwoman
why didn't they create a title called
spiderwomen and have silk spidergwen and
Spiderwoman all going up in their own
ventures in one title then once that was
done it all spins off into their own
individual titles such a good idea no
and I agree with you that that's what I
was wondering cuz like I read just read
the end of the other Spiderwoman and it
says that like she's like oh I'm getting
a new costume it's time for a change and
it's funny because Carol Danver is like
really you're going to finally start
dressing appropriately for your
age Spiderman was like this coming from
the girl whose butt was hanging out for
like 20 years I'll tell you exactly why
they did that by the way and it's just
it was just for them it was uh we're
going to look at the numbers and like
okay number one spiderverse is selling
like hot cakes number two it's a direct
tie in to spiderverse and if you looked
at the sales like the spiderverse tiin
were selling really well and so as a
result if they make spiderverse number
one directly tied in with spiderverse
and it's riding it's not like coming off
the heels of it it's happening dur in
the thick of it then you have a really
strong selling Spiderwoman number one
and you can point to it and say like
this sold really well and you never mind
that it was just literally a like Point
like five point you know chapter 5.2 in
the ongoing spiderverse story but you
know objectively you can look back like
six months and go like spiderverse one
sold you know 60,000 copies and you know
that's why it that's why they did that
no that doesn't that doesn't count all
right you you can't oh but that's how
that's why they did it it's just that
like they are they are s they are
salesmen like that's you know they're
just trying but's see that's that's
skewing the result okay you can't start
a lemonade stand and then park it
outside of Disneyland and say hey guys
look how awesome it is to sell lemonade
like selling lemonade makes you a bunch
of money no selling lemonade at
Disneyland makes you a bunch of money no
but yeah but if you sell your lemonade
for like a dollar less outside outside
you know Disneyland you will sell your
lemonade I think part go ahead Rob
here's the problem Spiderwoman number
one sold well because it was part of
spiderverse yeah because if you wanted
to know what was going on with the
master Weaver you had to get Spiderwoman
like you had to you had to read the
Spiderwoman stories if you want to know
what's going on with the master Weaver
like why is all this happening and
what's this guy been manipulating
whatever all right if you really want to
see whether or not Spiderwoman is going
to be a good selling title wait till
spiderverse is totally over give it like
a month after and then just see what
happens and I guarantee you it's going
to tank entirely because nobody cares
about
Spiderwoman there's reason why they
cancel that's why they're changing her
costume now yeah no they're actually
giving it a legit thing I person I feel
like Marvel and DC I mean we we've
already discussed event fatigue you know
events are buring us out nobody wants to
read them so I think that they've caught
on having 12 to 15 issue events just
doesn't function but I think when it
came to like you know um uh what's his
name the guy who does it Dan slot yeah
he was like oh I I I need to tell this
story but I need to I need to get more
in there but I but they Marvel's telling
me make it six issues right so so I
think the answer was oh we'll frontload
it into Spiderwoman and this other book
called Scarlet spiders there I have a 12
issue story arc but right but he didn't
write those like those are they had to
give them to different creative teams so
he didn't even get to tell that story
like that's not a story he wanted to
tell I think it was just they were like
oh man that first issue sold crazy we
could probably tie the [__] out of it
just like spider Island like spider
Island was great but like there were
like five unnecessary Titans with
that or it could be like Civil War where
there's like 46 unnecessary tians oh God
there were okay you know what after
doing Civil War after explaining Civil
War over like 20 videos for for those of
you guys out there in the chat who are
like I want to start reading Civil War
you need you need the Civil War main
story and you need Civil War Front Line
and that's
it may Cable in Deadpool if you really
want to you don't need you don't need
front line I would argue you don't even
need front line I I thought front line
added a richer story to Civil War it did
but they didn't work together so so it's
like Jenkins and Miller are telling two
different stories but two different
groups of people I don't not really CU
you got Ben Riley there when Thor when
like the the when was it Ragnarok when
the robot Thor shows up and like kills
uh Goliath I mean like he's he's there
he's like oh my God everything's popping
off and it's total pandemonium there are
some things that kind of don't make
sense though where they're like Tony
Stark's making a bunch of money off
damage control Inc and like like Ben
yuck and U or not I I think I said Ben
Ry before benuck and Ben and benuck and
Peter Parker are the ones that figure
out what was going on and then like okay
well I mean what like what happened with
this and they're like nothing yeah
that's it that's it he's still the bad
guy even though he's not the bad guy
they're going to talk about Civil War
now for the next hour so what do
you no that's that's that's the problem
I think with with like Marvel events
like Marvel events are fun like Marvel
events are cool but I think I think
you're kind of right because I was
thinking about this you know a little
while ago I think you're kind of right
when when they say when you guys say
that they have totally unnecessary
tie-ins because like 65% I might even
say 80% of Civil War was unnecessary who
who cares that I mean why did why why in
God's name did they need to make a comic
this was literally how they brought
Heroes for higher back Tony Stark Reed
Richards and Hank Pim said let's go to
the let's go to Heroes for hire the
newest one led by Missy KN and say you
guys need to go find Captain America
Captain America managed to
single-handedly evade an entire Shield
Helicarrier like dispatch Shield
soldiers hold off the entire combination
of Tony Stark's Avengers yet somehow
Heroes for high is going to be able to
track him down and bring him in like
that's that's those kind of things or
higher I I and they weren't even they
weren't even important like the only one
who even mattered was like black cat
yeah and she was she was like that was
it like I have to say my favorite part
of Civil War was probably the most
irrelevant part of the whole thing which
was The Runaways and the Young
Avengers The
Runaways
man I I got into that way later and I
was like sad that I missed their
involvement with the Marvel Universe
proper like after reading like I think
uh I read the first volume of runaways
and I read Children's Crusade and I'm
like yeah these are cool what happened
them see I still distinctly remember the
Young Avengers coming out because I was
kind of falling out of love with the
Teen Titans at that time and Avengers
came out was like okay this is what the
Teen Titans should be doing and then
they did it
yeah so let's let's go to another topic
that we actually haven't touched on the
last couple of weeks and I think this is
a very good one for f to touch on with
us here uh the TNT announcement of the
Teen Titans liveaction TV show
yeah the uh okay so the the announced
cast for this is going to be Dick
Grayson AKA Robin Nightwing Barbara
Gordon as the former Batgirl that's
they're putting her in as the that's
what it's flagged as in this article I
know no I'm just saying like how you
going to make that work you can't man uh
they were going to bring in Hawk and
Dove which finally wait wait but here
here's what here's what I want to know
um and in in this apparently they're
going to it's going to be Hank Hall and
Dawn and they're romantically involved
now I'm not a huge Hawk and Dove fan but
isn't it pretty much like Dove like 20
years younger than him and he always
kind of protects her from everything
I've seen it depends on what version
you're talking about you talking about
the Rob lifeyield version or you talking
about like the
the the old version like pre neww 52 or
like there's like sometimes they're like
they're they're they're romantically
involved sometimes Dove's a
girl no that's Don Granger Don Granger
is the second Dove okay because I was
gonna say like wouldn't it be more
interesting to make them like men the
dudes the two dudes yeah like wouldn't
that be more interesting to see I don't
know I always just assume that Haw and
Dove were together anyway I didn't
realize that like well I honestly I
think that's what everyone's assumption
was and that's why the writers went to
the the two female team but then I think
the the exact same rumors continued well
now instead of two game men it's two
lesbians right and they're like no no
one's in the book and it's like cares
man crap mix mix the teams mix the
teams then it's okay great now it's like
everything else good
job uh and then we also have Raven and
Starfire is gonna be live action will
she be
orange I hope
so no
person possible I think she'll be orange
I think she'll well if she does she'll
just have like an orange spray on tan
yeah she'll be tan if cosplayers can
pull off her being orange and make it
look good fuing TV show can yeah I don't
know man you'd think so but I don't
think some of these TV shows have the
budget of
cosplayers no way that they're gonna do
to be fair that one of the main reasons
I hate The Flash TV show is that [__]
Flash costume what's WR with the Flash
costume no one's going to run at the
speed of light and leather they're just
he's not going to be the fastest man
alive he's going to be the most chafed
man
alive a mad man his bollocks will be
hiding in his
stomach it's not technically leather
it's some kind of weird flame [__]
material that they created yeah that
looks like Lea that looks a lot like Lea
probably feels like it
too and it looks and feels like red
leather so okay so since F made this
lovely face at it was this the first
time you heard about the live action
show please don't tell me no no it
wasn't so we haven't touched on this at
all and the big the rumor is that it's
going to be set in the same universe as
arrow and Flash which means
it'll you didn't know about that so
it'll be ultra American enjoy yes so
basically just like superg girlw it's
going to be in the universe but slightly
removed so is the Teen Titan show so how
do you feel about having everyone in red
Le they will be you just put the heroes
in spandex if it looks good on
cosplayers it will look good on TV stop
being so ashamed of the fact that it's a
comic book and stop trying to put make
it all dark and gritty and everyone's in
leather have fun with it which they
won't do because they clearly they they
look at comic books and say these are no
fun let's make it dark and gritty in
every
adaptation other than Guardians of the
Galaxy what blows my mind about arrow is
he has leather hoodie yeah I don't know
if anybody's ever worn a leather like
even close to leather material on a
hoodie but you can't hear or see
anything it's like a tunnel yeah yeah
man back in the
day if you would like to see what your
beloved DC characters would look like if
they were not in Span or if they were in
Spandex and on television you need only
YouTube the Justice League liveaction
pilot and watch your beloved characters
like Fire and Ice and Captain Adam and
the Flash in their spandex costumes in
with a TV budget the TV budget of course
is like Lois and Clark the new adventur
Superman but
wow TV TV I have to disagree the leather
costumes I'm not against and I'm telling
you right now if if this is the actual
cast I bring it in there you're going to
have Nightwing and leather that's gonna
be a given I mean no question it's just
you know so is so is Barbara Gordon if
she's in the back girls going to be the
Lea outfit Hawk and Dove will be in some
weird costumes it maybe it won't be
leather but I'm telling you right now
Starfire will be wearing the Forever 21
outfit in Le yeah well they're not going
to make her like wearing a bikini people
parents groups and that's is the problem
F you you have to understand everything
that we make everything in on this side
of the pond is uh dictated by parents
groups you see I rate mothers haven't
had sex in like 25 years they determine
everything that you see on tele telion
and if it doesn't have that lovely
Nathan Filan in it then they're really
going to have they're going to bring the
hammer down
so if they have Starfire in like a
bikini or in a high fashioned Italian
swimwear outfit and she's fighting crime
in it uh these you know these Midwestern
uh moms are going to lose their [__] and
don't these midw Midwestern moms aren't
they like against comics in general
aren't they they don't even know like
they they knew that they were like
that's something the children read and
so like they can't number one like let
me tell you something I like really
quick really quick go sell
go I was in when I was in grad school I
was talking to uh I don't know what the
hell the context was but like we were
talking about culture or something like
that and one of the girls in the class
said something like she's like I I met
somebody who reads comic books and I'm I
I keep everything when I'm work when I'm
working when I'm working with like teach
when I'm working with teachers when I'm
in a school environment that I don't
interact with people I do not go like oh
I love Comics because I know that's just
GNA pigeon hole me and it was it's a
mess so uh I just keep quiet and she was
talking about how she read she knew this
guy who reads comic books now in their
back that like in their mid 20s she's
like so isn't he like a
pedophile that was the immediate
assumption she made
and when she said this out loud our
professor was
like like not
no which is the
answer but yeah like what you said was
kind of ignorant but at the same time
it's a grown man reading comic books so
there is something wrong with him was
the cultural mindset in my liberal arts
college not the one I went to for my
bachelors's but later on uh I would
actually leave that school eventually
but like the point here is like the the
the the American cultural mindset at
least and I'm sure you guys have
close-minded jackasses who don't
appreciate Comics or pop culture in
general uh but there is a there's a
stigma that has existed since I would
say Corruption of the innocent like that
book that was written by that crazy
person in the 50s uh there's a book
written by the by like a preacher I
think or some jackass in the 1950s and
he like wrote about like comic books and
like
B and be movies are like encouraging our
children to masturbate and be and be Eng
code Authority well the Comm cold
Authority came a little later and they
those people that's by the way same
people who don't want your Starfire to
wear that outfit uh they they were like
a board of people who like said this can
go in and this can't which is hilarious
because like we could have zaz a man who
killed people and then carved the like
number of women that he or people that
he killed into his flesh that was okay
but Starfire can't dress like that
because that's weird well I mean even I
just did a video about um Daredevil and
black widow like their love story and
the same thing kot Authority said you
cannot acknowledge that they are
together right they can live together
they can s side kick together they can
do everything together but you can not
acknowledge an actual relationship that
was part of the com cour Authority like
at no point like it was like the com
code Authority was like Hey guys here's
like this Antiquated ass mindset that we
have from way back then and let's just
keep it that way so like you can hold
hands yeah like well they was it were
like your facial expressions are the F
okay okay
F I'm voting I'm voting hold on I'm
voting that from this point forward on
the weekly poll we have F on every
episode and all is is just a face on the
camera just reacting just reacting just
reacting to everything okay F so here's
the deal so so way back in the day and I
think it was either in the 19 yeah it
was the 1950s when it happen 1960s maybe
but um some yeah the comments code
Authority like it came Comics code but
oh well if you don't know about Comics
code then don't worry about it oh
yeah I'm still getting over like I knew
B Comics code but I didn't think that
carried over till today oh yeah in
England in England we're just so
accepting that 14y olds are gonna
[__] no that is that is categorically
unacceptable here're we're in a day and
age where we have one of the highest
grossing television shows on MTV is Teen
Mom or teen pregnancies or whatever you
know or Honey Boo Boo but oh my God God
forbid a grown man enjoys reading comic
books you know it's only within the last
10 years since comic books have become
like popular thanks to movies that it's
even becoming more acceptable it's it's
still kind of a joke to this day like I
was talking to someone um like a year
ago when I first started doing the comic
book stuff and they're they're like
they're like hey I need you to know if
you can I was I was working like
part-time at some other job I just got
out of the military and I still kind of
trying to do things long story short but
I was working part time there and I'm
like I can't do it Thursdays cuz that's
my comic book day where I go and record
stuff for my channel and stuff like that
this is when we were first launching and
they thought I meant oh I just go around
and dick around and have fun and you
know and I'm just that weird guy and
like because and I found this out
because like a month later they're like
hey can you work this Thursday and I was
like no I have to go to the comic book
day where I go do the recordings and
stuff they're like but do you really
need to go buy comic books like really
like that's your
reaction yeah I don't I don't know I
mean it's it's it's funny to me I think
when you look at like the culture like
American culture looking at looking at
the idea of comic books because it's
it's like I mean is it really that weird
like is it really all that strange like
like like America just made a movie
about a guy that beats the [__] out of a
chick that made $90 million over the
course of a weekend like is it really
that strange that like we're doing like
we're looking at comic books like that
doesn't Advocate that kind of stuff but
um I don't know like at the end of the
day I think the problem that you have is
a lot of people for some reason or
another just aren't willing to like
accept the fact that like they're badass
and comic book comic books comic books
have great stories that get tied into
them like great Concepts that get tied
into them and you can do a lot with the
idea of a comic book or even reflect
culture wherever it is that comic book
is being written out of but I don't know
yeah well the fact is like uh you're not
going to see Starfire in that outfit
you're gonna
see discussion like he going to be in
that in in that just had a 10minute of
basically at 10 minutes of s cramping on
F hopes and dreams oh no I'm sorry fact
that she's the fact that she's in it at
all is astounding to me because I can
imagine them going like going down the
list why is Beast Boy not on that
because he turns into freaking animals
and that cost up so like the fact is you
can imagine them being like okay pitch
me Teen Titans or just or or Titans I
don't know if they're gonna be teens uh
but pitch me Titans like okay uh Robin
great that's a kid in an outfit with a
cape done that saves us boatloads of
cash like Arrow but little done cuz
that's what producer is like cuz TV and
movies I don't know if you know this but
like and by let me be more condescending
but like no the uh with TV movies they
you need to be able to pitch your whole
idea in 15 seconds and usually what they
do and what they their their cultural
conversation is thing you know plus
thing you know equals thing I'm
explaining so for them they're like okay
Nightwing who's that older bat like
older Robin okay that's great so it's
like Batman but like without all the
Batman terrific that saves US money
Batman without Batman that's exactly
what like they refer to him in this ad
like in the in the gray solo run who
else there like Raven okay what what's
Raven Raven is a girl emo okay done emo
great what powers does she have uh she
Blends into Shadow and she can teleport
we can no that's camera trickery bye and
Teen Titans that's that's that's the
audience is suggesting we we'd create
let's do that guys
no didn't talk about r costume but I'm
like 90% sure it will be like a leather
sort of leotard kind of thing with a Le
think the Scott Lael run about where she
was pretty much full body yeah and she
had this weird like feather thing over
her head oh my God if they do that I'm
gonna kill
them that was the worst oh we're gonna
keep her hoodie but it's it's feathers
because she's Raven get it yeah no you
know what she will dress like a like a
like a the craft goth chick so toally
culturally uh ignorant and she'll wear a
necklace with a bird or a feather on it
and that will be the Raven reference uh
and then finally you pitch Starfire and
you're like okay who so who's Starfire
she's an alien oh okay Like a Star Trek
alien where we could just put ridges on
her
forehead she's orange orange how about
black because that's TV uh and then like
okay what's her PO she can fly uh and
she shoots energy beams oh my God what
and she dresses uh like an Italian Su
model yeah she's not going to be in the
show I'm sorry she can have like a
cameo but then they say but she has
boobs yeah but she has boobs and I
thought f is gonna be our team titan
Ranter s's going nuts over there s's
going ham that's just because I hate
TV I don't I don't know I mean it's it's
I
don't see the reason I'm not saying much
is because I've had this weird
perception of American TV because the
only American TV I really watch is
community rupal's drag
race you like Community Well Community
is a fantastic show I'm sorry to say
it's like watched by eight people here
yeah and that's why it's on Yahoo now oh
is it is it going on got freaking
cancelled well I know I got canell I
didn't know it was on Yahoo no Yahoo
picked it up it's gonna be season six
comes out in the this year I guess uh
and it's GNA be really cool because
Donald Glover is coming back no if you
want to know about like American TV like
sit down and watch like like what is it
the secret Housewives of Los Angeles or
whatever the hell that is or something
like that or or like Keeping Up with the
Kardashians like that is American like
that's that's what a majority watch TV
is mostly ruled by like CW crap like
it's like that style where it's like
it's Gothic and supernaturally and and
but at the same time they're all going
to have love interests and we're all
going to say some trendy cool things to
to fit in with everyone
and every show follows that format
including arrow and Flash so a bit like
what Charmed and Buffy the Vampire
Slayer started back up it started up
back in the 90s and then it died and
needed to stay [__] dead yeah well
that's not and then
just is that channel like that's who
they that's what they make like like how
can we okay I see I see your idea for a
grim and gritty show about a an angst
ridden superhero who just wants to clean
up the streets but how can we make it
more like the Gilmore
Girls you know you know what's funny the
funniest thing ever though is like it's
cuz they doing in a Flash all the time
like it's the same thing I've always had
this argument with Buffy and they always
like oh we make these cool and trendy
conversations I have never like oh I'm
just going to go to the random coffee
shop and have a 20-minute conversation
about some random nerdy stuff that makes
no goddamn sense at all and like
straight out of the TV show and like
they're like oh like the Quinton
Tarantino discussions were s around at a
at a um at a a restaurant and argued
about the Tipping and the the values
behind
it character for a long time that is the
greatest okay to totally Sidetrack off
of comic books the entire like Harvey
kitel like all those guys need to get
back together again for just like that
five minutes and and just do it again
like Steve Bimi needs to sit there or
they could update it and Steve well no
because they all died and spoilers for a
30-year-old movie but spoilers dude okay
so you really couldn't like update it
but they need to all come back and
reenact that scene again would be great
be amazing B on the comments okay F you
watched the community have you seen Big
Bang Theory I have and I hate it yes
good Big Bang is bad for you know what's
funny though because my wife is French
like I said so she's European and she
hates all those shows too she can't
stand any of them I have to watch them
with like headphones on in the corner of
the house like I'm watching Big B Theory
Big B the is bad for you they're
laughing at us I know track is at you
that's not a laugh track for us we're
not we don't think that that's hilarious
that's for that's that's the that's the
popular culture that's like people who
you know were really upset about deflate
gate laughing at us okay that's what Big
Bang Theory is that laugh track is just
our entire High School careers like big
that's that's what it is man like that's
see I was I had this conversation with a
friend of mine and we were talking about
Sheldon from Big Bang Theory and we said
Sheldon is not
hilarious like Sheldon is what people
think nerds are like that's that's like
Sheldon is a reflection of what people
think nerds are and like just sit around
and like make you know nerdy references
about physics and stuff because who
gives a [__] about how fast you TR
through a black hole and so on that guy
uh the main
character what's his
name I watch that show what's his name
Leonard Leonard Leonard is the is is a
is like that self-loathing I wish I were
cool and I wish I could be accept
by popular people who have no
personality like makes me so angry I
hate that show well you should watch the
show by the way the YouTube has a great
thing where they just remove the laugh
track and it just kills the show really
it deadens the where they're just like
Sheldon I want to touch girl like I like
what's his name uh kther being like I
want to sexually harass
women and a long pause and then everyone
being like like oh whatever your name is
guys it totally kills the show oh Indian
stereotype LOL like that's why I got
really angry at this season of King of
the nuts King Of The Nerds is another
one no s was like by the way I watched
them all because apparently I'm an
addict for hate well season one wasn't
bad it wasn't bad watch season two and
season three I've just been offensive
they are so offensive so so offensive
and the comic book guy they got every
Comic Book Guy they get is just is a
disaster but like that huge dude I can't
remember his name cuz and thank God for
that cuz like I won't lose some precious
moment that I had in my mind from like
when I was a child because I won't
remember that kid's name but like that
that guy from the episode of from the
most recent episode of King of the Nerds
e guy he does not repres he is not us no
he is not Comics well the the problem
with things like Big Bang Theory King Of
The Nerds stuff like that is and I agree
with you they are mocking the the
culture of geekdom and all this other
stuff but it also because of stuff like
that and the Marvel movies and and it
stuff like that has has brought geekdom
to the Forefront it's made it cool you
know it's cool be a guy that want to go
read comics and stuff now because 10
years ago you we were the guy that was
self-loathing and all man I don't can't
tell anyone that I like to play Magic
the Gathering on the weekends [__] yeah
man you walk into high school and tell
everybody that you love Magic the
Gathering like you're going to get your
ass kicked dude not today not today man
not today man there are magic clubs I
work high schools let me tell you they
they like it actually blew my mind uh I
went on a a tour of the high school that
I work in the in the district I work at
and uh there was a what I would consider
to be based on my cultural mindset a
jock and he was giving the tour he's
like yes so you could join like the uh
you know the football team if you want
or you could join like the magic the
Gathering club which is really awesome
and like you could go join up with the
with the color guard they're pretty much
they're pretty baller and and I'm like
just this complete weird meshing of
every where no one hated anybody and I'm
like are you all like on on something
like if they finding something the duct
work like it was so bizarre but like but
but wonderful I was like this is great
I'm sure it's completely not I wish I
could go back to high school nowadays oh
God man you want to be in high school in
this world today yeah to be fair this is
just temporary I mean this is like what
the not saying I want to go back to high
school 10 years from now no right now
while it's valid yeah I mean like no uh
being yeah but at the same time like I'm
sure be if you like being a nerd is cool
like H uh like that I love this there's
a meme of a of a chick with black rimmed
glasses and she's the word nerd on her
Palm like I love that Meme but I would
love to see it with like a guy as well
just like to see the because both both
of them are phonies uh but this whole
like I'm such a nerd I saw the new Star
Trek movie and you're like no but the
second you start like launching into
like did you know like will L fleas and
the Red Lanterns and they're gonna be
like whoa oh did you see that by the way
everyone's calling you a red lantern in
the comments I am a red
lantern me and uh me and U what's his
name
dexstar you have dexstar at the house
yeah well I got three cats so I'm
totally all about dear one of them can
be dexstar we got this it's cool I'm I'm
part of the Indigo tribe one of the two
parastic ones yeah what what does that
leave me and Rob to be I don't want to
be green those guys are lame I will I
will be I'll be John I'll be John
Stewart there we go yeah I'll be the
I'll be the black green I mean I'm black
why not be the black Green Lantern guy
John Stewart man you're guy Garden guy
Gard maybe you guys can answer me this
because I know F reads DC and stuff when
did when since when are they trying to
make Guy Gardner cool again cuz I just
watched The Lego I just watched The Lego
Justice League movie where they go to
Bizarro world yeah and they have gr
Gardner in there and I'm like that's
bizarre and even my wife was like why
did they pick guy Garder like because
they think if they just believe really
hard you know Nostalgia that's why
because like people remember and like
Guy Gardner even though Guy Gardner was
never cool he had the lamest haircut
ever and he wore like a Le jacket like
AER and like every time you saw a guy
Garder he was like kick ass and you're
like shut up Guy Gardner like you know
Batman punched you one time and you were
out in your ass for like a week so shut
the hell up
guy like I don't know why but I'm all I
never like Guy Gardner will never redeem
himself in my eyes like Guy Gardner is
the guy who like thought he was gonna
kick Doomsday's ass and instead was like
beaten by like a you know by like a
stiff
breeze his silly mushroom cut the
problem with Guy Gardner is that guy
Gardner originally was a Green Lantern
and then he did the whole Yellow Lantern
thing before G an were cool well he had
sinestro's ring yeah and then he was the
warrior like the wrestler no you don't
know the point where he discovered he
had alien DNA in his genes and he had
the ability to morph his limbs into
Weaponry yeah I missed that
part and that now he's a red lantern
he's okay as a red lantern I like the
idea of Guy Gardner being a red lantern
but I wish they'd skipped all the crap
and just gone from him being like I'm a
Green Lantern and the Guardians be like
get the hell out of here guy Garder and
then him getting like sinestro's ring
and being like I'm still a badass and
then having everyone go get the hell out
of here Guy Gardner having go like oh
screw this I hate everybody and then the
red ler going hey guy Garder you look
like you're a member of our team and
he's like yeah F everybody I'm gonna be
angry all the time I'm totally down for
that I like that change I've always said
if I ever got a chance to like write for
like Green Lantern comics and do
something based off The Wizard of Oz it
was just something just someone looking
for the ultimate ring and they have to
throw water on the evil
witch
so but no this podcast has gone
everywhere it it has gone everywhere but
no like it's see it's it's going going
back to the whole the whole comic book
culture thing like it amazes me like
looking back because like in high school
like like when I was in high school you
know you couldn't you couldn't be the
guy who was like Hey I'm into comics and
and I'm sure like you know you guys ran
into the same circumstance but then all
of a sudden we're here and then like
we're combining the whole YouTube comic
book Community into one big thing so
like it's funny to me that people people
take that stance and then it's also
funny like when you look then and then
you look now and like s was saying like
there's there's really no concept like
will I mean you got like The Avengers
film which is huge and Avengers 2 Age of
Ultron which is huge and you got like
comic book hers which is huge and in
truth it's the movies that made it
acceptable you know I agree with you
guys on that that it's the movies that
made it cool to be interested in comics
but you guys are also right in the sense
that it is the movies based on
characters and like those characters are
the cool ones to talk about like you
could talk about wolver rain all day
long yeah man wolver rain this and that
and Tony Stark yeah man he's awesome you
know but then like you said when you
were just some obscure character like
hey man did you guys like you guys know
about blue Marvel it's like dude man
like get get that nerdiness the hell out
of here man back up man you can't go too
obscure that and that's the Fine Line we
all cross and I know F has done some
really obscure characters on his channel
because I've seen some of the videos
where I was like who is this man by the
way being I the comic story and I'm like
who is this what the only English comic
YouTuber and the only English comic
YouTuber who will dare talk about like
these character it's just because my
mindset is like obviously due to the
nature of our Channel like we do admit
like there are fake Geeks out there and
we are going to attract them but but
then I always say if they're going to go
and watch the more obscure characters
they're putting in some extra efforts so
there might be something that you can
kind of tap into like when everything
Fades yeah we can just kind of make them
a geek forever and I should say that's a
great that's a great message and I
really like that you kind of like hey if
you're here just because you like Batman
maybe you might also be interested in
this it's the concept of like G having
like Spider-Man in your night watch book
like hey if you don't know who this
character is you might come because you
read this guy uh but I like I I don't
know I'm I shouldn't uh I didn't mean to
imply uh you know like rage against
against fake Geeks because while I
resent uh you know like I love Batman
I'm such a nerd LOL like I think that's
lame but I like anybody who is willing
to participate in something that I en
joy and like communicate on some
personal level is really is cool and
good for them and like so I I appreciate
that and so you know I I don't I don't
appreciate ignorance and
close-mindedness but like anybody who's
a who's a geek fake or otherwise is
welcome in my community I think that's
the way it's oh yeah well then that's
that's how I look I mean that that's why
when I I do things I I touch I mean I
throw in the Obscure guys once in a
while but I touch on all the big stuff
because oh yeah well well that's what's
you know people want to know about
that of course they do you know yeah
people that [__] me I like just
intentionally don't do the big stuff
because there's already a lot of
histories of De pulls out that you don't
need another one no it's true although I
will say this I am officially doing the
origin of Batman because I don't think
anybody's actually like everyone knows
it but no one's actually G no like okay
we all know his parents freaking died
what happened between then yeah he
didn't just put a Batman cape on the
next day and be like I'm Batman woo
so are you just going to do like Batman
year One like no I'm doing the actual
Origins as retold in the new 52 which
basically ties it into the whole Red
Hood game yeah that's cool cool yeah
that's zero that's zero year man you're
cover zero year no I'm not touching
you're not touching you're not doing
zero year not zero year no so I I do
want to ask you this I'm I'm going
through your videos I'm trying to find
the most obscure one that I can see that
you touched on F I just want to know
your mindset on it so I I it's either
got to be Flex
Metallo or
pixie see I would say it's probably be
Kane where is it be Kane it was back
when I was wearing the wig so it's
towards way back there yeah oh Quinton
queer the kid Omega
Quint that's a mispronunciation in a
half I'm guessing you don't read much
X-Men yeah no I actually I I hate the I
hated the whole Wolverine and the X-Men
School run and I like X-Men my favorite
book on X-Men right now is the all new
X-Men because we got the originals back
I'm not a fan of like kid apocalypse and
oh this is a weird guy from another
planet and I like I like the idea of
Wolverine and the X-Men see I loved
Wolverine in the X-Men cuz my favorite
X-Men run is the new X-Men from like
back in 2003 oh yes so like that I'm I
don't know I've got a thing about Teen
teams and so Wolverine and the X-Men's
right up my street and then yeah the new
X-Men introduced um I think it had was
that Grant Morrison's run that
introduced kidega or was it the new
X-Men I think it was
hisor era oh my God here is this demig
God powerful kid who can who has like
who's insane and then like Emma Frost
walks in and she's like hey Cyclops I
know Jean Gray's kind of here but she's
kind of not here so like let's mentally
bang and he's like okay we can kind of
and then Jean gr's like oh my God what
are you doing you're psychically having
sex like you're chea on me and he's like
it's not what it looks like no it's
totally what it looks like it's what it
looks like I'm totally banging this way
more interesting version of you new
X-Men I read new X-Men fost it was it
was going through I see that you covered
Moka Maga I actually watched that that's
really good yeah I love Madoka Maga oh
man I watched the whole
series now we're going to weird obscure
stuff right here I have I have no idea
what's going on right now like I don't
know what you Tiffany is Indie and anime
girl on our Channel and she also you
know main contributor let me tell you
something like my experience with anime
is extended to like Dragon Ball Z and
that's
it about as deep as it goes let me tell
you something that MAA Magi a girl show
was kind of really cool I'm just gonna
toss that out there kind of really cool
well because like when I was a kid I
watched Sailor Moon and I'll say that
because it's cool to be a geek right
guys but like for I don't think we cross
that line no you're 12 okay you're 12
years old it's uh it's four it's five in
the morning the bus you have to kill
like 30 minutes before your mom gets up
and you turn on the TV and the only
thing on is Sailor Moon okay okay but
here's your only Redemption which one
was your favorite character on that
Jupiter now see that no mine was Tuxedo
Mask when I had Tu mask was super
cool and he was totally pimp too because
he's like hey Serena what's up you're
both wrong you both have dirty
mouths I'm a huge salent Moon fan I
don't okay when I was a kid you're right
it came on before Dragon Ball Z it was
like the action hour yeah and like and
it was also the Ronin Warriors the Ron
Warriors I was getting ready to say
Ronin Warriors it was like sa Moon Ronin
Warriors and it was Sailor Moon DBZ and
you're like uh and it was the situation
all right I guess I'll watch I can't
drive I can't do anything and you're
like all right I'll watch Sailor Moon
and then we'll we'll go I guess I'll
grudgingly watch this amazing but like I
I distinctly remember watching Sailor
Moon as a child and the two lesbians
appeared in it and I remember watching
it with my mom and I was about 7 years
old trying to figure out if those two
girls were lesbians or not they are what
and then I've watched the Japanese one
God knows how many times over now it's
like oh yeah how did how why would you
even try and say their cousins oh yeah
is like you got them because in America
we didn't get them until way later and
then they were like they're cousins and
they're just really friendly really
friendly that came way later like after
like after the first season they were
like okay um how we're gonna work this
but anyway we're going off topic but I
just want to say I like that show but I
I really dug that MGA Maga girl show
because I was like Wow take the magical
girl concept and like turns it on its
ear it takes like these like these core
these core like pop anime Concepts and
makes it into something really
interesting and I really thought that
well you know that one I got stuck with
it weird because I I'm very on my anime
anime goes in a very weird Direction
very easily so to get me to watch like I
will watch them all but I need to have
like a quite a few sources telling me no
like Attack on Titan I held off on that
until everyone was like look it's the
coolest thing ever you need to watch
this okay fine you know Full Metal
Alchemist I watched the original
subtitle version before they translated
the whole thing ni but magic and M I
can't I never could say yeah whatever
the magical girl one I was like no way
I'm watching a show about a 9-year-old
girl who gets magical princess powers
whatever and my buddy's just like he's
like's like watch the first three
episodes if you get out of the first
three episodes and you don't want to
watch more then I will leave you alone
and I will give you a 100 bucks I'm like
I G make a 100 bucks like I love
watching the third episode with people
because it gets towards the end of the
episode and you can see them going I'm
not goingon to watch anymore not going
to watch and then the thing happens and
then they just go what oh my God that is
a mind Bender I was like that was cool
like that I I was I had enormous amount
of respect for that I also like uh and
of course we're we're we're gonna move
on from anime I think but really quick
we should start an anime explain Channel
Rob nope not
happening see it on TV little house in a
week anime explain star you can't steal
it I came up with it all right go well
it's mine now it's mine now what I'm
taking F and we're gonna go do it f
we're making anim never
mind you know what um Dab's on fast no
it's it's
um no I was I was never watching Sailor
Moon like I was watching Legend I was
never watching Sailor Moon no man like
like okay here here was my thing all
right I got home from school well school
got at at about 3:20 I got home at
around 3:40 maybe closer to to 4 o'clock
all right I was watching like Legends of
the Hidden Temple Rocco's Modern Life if
it came on um I was watching because
because like Rocko's Modern Life
wouldn't come on consistently like it
would come on and they would show a
couple episodes and like it wouldn't
come back for a week and then I was
watching like Doug and then it was
Dragon Ball Z and then I do my homework
and then it was it was WCW and WWF is
what it was like that was that was my
[__] that was my jam yeah dude Legend
Temple we should do we should do a
classic codeon exp you always make us
sound so freaking old every episode you
guys remember that show from the 8S
what's amazing hey people in the chat if
you YouTube L of the enchant of the
Hidden Temple every episode every
episode is on there and there's the one
episode of that one girl who spent two
minutes trying to put together the
Shrine of the silver that's every
episode by the way there's a great um
there's a great Roku Channel called Nick
rebooted where it basically it's just if
you have your get your Roku everybody
and uh set up your DB your uh your your
Nick your Nick rebooted Channel because
it's literally like having Nickelodeon
on and it will throw on like old
commercials between the old shows but
it'll show them like in a in in a order
that makes sense so like it'll be Are
You Afraid of the Dark and then it'll be
like you know uh whatever something cool
like Nick arcade oh God Nick arcade man
playing those CRA games those shitty G
for the record I'm just going to throw
this out there guys I think we've proven
that we don't have to always discuss
comic books on this podcast because
everyone's watching and totally going
along with us out online clai explained
thank you Brian yeah oh my hentai
explained okay which one of you three
wants to do that Channel with me man F
that
noise explained but no okay
all right we got this we got that is a
show that is a that is a money-making
idea so you know how they used to film
Legends of the Hidden Temple right like
you know why it got so screwed up no
okay so the reason why kids could never
solve the puzzle of the Shrine of the
silver monkey is because like 12 hours
would have passed between the time they
started it and the time they finished it
like they would bring in like like four
or five groups of kids and everybody
would do like the first part like where
they would cross the mo and then you L
you lost a lot of people in theat dude
man there were a lot of men that went
down in the
boat but uh and it was always that one
stupid kid like that one kid who's like
who's like I just can't stay on the like
how how difficult is it I can't stand on
the Boogie Board and hold the Rope at
the same time all you have to do is hold
the damn thing and move across like how
difficult could it really be you know
what that kid F save me f that kid took
a dive for the Huffy bike yeah butu bike
if you kill yourself so they would they
would do it all in section so by the
time you finish like if you were the
first team to go and you cross the moat
and let's say that for whatever reason
like the silver snakes uh the silver
snakes won because they always do
because the thing no the silver snakes
win the red Jaguars that were pimp yeah
the red Jaguars are pretty pimp but um
anyway if you were the first one to
cross the moat then it would be like 11
hours later by the time you got to the
Temple Run if you made it and so like
like this one kid he was I guess he was
on the show before when he was a kid and
uh he he did like an AMA on Reddit and
he was like he explained the whole thing
he's like that's why cuz like your
adrenaline's running and you're
exhausted and so you just can't like you
can't figure it all out but I I still
don't understand that concept adrenaline
running my ass all right you've got
three pieces you got a base you got a
middle and you got a head you know what
I I will I will V to that because um
recently because I'm trying I'm trying
to get in better shape before we start
doing these conventions in the summer
and crap I've i' I switched up my my
routine from just doing like lifting to
doing like CrossFit and like I can
straight lift no problem like 250 lbs
but if I do CrossFit and then go try to
bench like 120 and I'm
like why is this not
working um there's no way there's no way
that this has gotten
heavier yeah and I could say like
because I do gymnastics it depends on
how like if your adrenaline's running
there is no way that you're going to be
doing Rings because they are going to be
swinging all over the place yeah yeah
exactly yeah
it was I don't I don't know like it's
it's you know I I I miss that show oh
one of my favorite things before we move
on one of my favorite things again no
move keep going one one of my favorite
things are everybody in the chat who
remembers legend of the Hidden Temple
you guys remember this you don't kids
yeah yeah a lot of those kids were just
stupid like yeah like om would be like
here's the story and he's like okay now
here's a question about the story and
they're like H three paragraphs kid yeah
and they don't know like like like a
Blackbeard had like a black beard and he
sailed on a ship and like he went to
this location and so they're like okay
cool and so he's like what's the
location Blackbeard went to and they're
like oh and there'll just be something
totally out in left field it's like you
[__] he just told you what it was like
like how difficult could it be to just
regurgitate what it was that he said I
don't know like they were just stupid
kids and like every every episode the
grand prize was a trip to space camp or
Colonial Williamsburg yeah that's true
that was like hey congratulations you
could to do your homework go your
grandma's house we didn't have legend of
the Hidden Temple here we had a
different version called raven where the
kids had to go to a training camp before
they were even allowed to be on the show
wow
what that noise yeah man you know funny
side note since we're here uh I I got a
good do remember the show Fear Factor
back in the day yes yes I remember
Tyrone bams was on episode of fear fact
no that was Universal Studios had a
exhib there It Was Fear Factor live and
it was like once a week or once a day or
whatever you could go sign up and be on
it oh cool between when I was on
vacation from my RQ while I was overseas
you get two weeks to come back home I
went to I went down there and I got I
got on it I I they put me on the show
and that stuff is the craziest thing
you've ever got to do like I mean back
then when I was in Peak shape because I
was overseas and I was you know early
20s and actually you know doing stuff
consistently and didn't eat
cheeseburgers every night you know
but like the first tasking was just to
do like at this point I was doing like
25 30 pull-ups no problem and the first
thing you had to do was just hold
yourself on a bar while they blew fans
at you in
Rain wow that's awesome right so I I had
a video it's long gone now but so like
but it's funny because like I can do
things no problem but within like 20
seconds I fell off of that thing now
everyone else fell off before me on that
one which is funny I was like the third
guy only the last one got voted off and
then the second task was you had to
swing on like this giant swing thing
while throwing octopuses at another guy
trying to catch them in a bucket welcome
to America fast yes I remember Fear
Factor but I don't remember that yeah
well that's no that was just the that
was the prelimin the Universal Studios
version but the coolest thing ever and
this is where I'm this is where the
story goes about the adrenaline thing
and losing track of what's going on and
all other stuff the last thing you had
to do was you had to run around the
arena first like you had to run on the
outside run back in and once you're in
inside you then had to get onto a car
that would then raise up and above
everything like three stories high and
you had to crawl around the car getting
keys that were hooked on the hood the
trunk and the doors unlock the trunk get
a fake missile launcher and then launch
it and actually hit a Target it's like a
Nerf you know Nerf or nothing
right but like you you'd be like oh
that's no problem I you know I I cuz
they had that cord on you too you were
going to fall off the cart you know oh
yeah you'd be like easiest thing ever no
it's not you're exhausted you got people
cheering for you you got all these
lights going on and you're dangling over
everything and your Adrena is going 90
mil an hour and you're like all right I
just got to get the GE R and I gotta go
the back and I gotta do this I got okay
okay okay here we go it suffice to say I
actually won it was so yeah and it was
funny because the prize was uh free
tickets back to Universal Studios for
the year I never came back for the year
oh they knew that they knew that they
were like sweet here you go here's
something you'll never use but yeah that
kind of stuff you get crazy and you're
just you're just like still put together
that effing monkey it's two pieces in a
head with a stick on it yep now see I
see they they need to like redo that
show make it for like adults but here's
a problem you would have like you would
have a situation where they would bring
on like some dude all right from like
the hood or from like a trailer park
where somebody were like like life is
rough and he's going to go through the
obstacle course and a temple guard's
going to come out and he's going to just
deck the guy just keep on going oh yeah
oh reach the kid and the kid's like no
and you're like he almost got knocked
out a little Insurance problem there but
uh I think they're going to do a show
like that they should pair up six people
from totally different walks of life
that never met each other like dude from
a trailer park a drag
queen you already hit a good combo show
yeah they call they call that the real
world
I thought that was Big Brother six
people from different walks of lives in
one house no but then you make them do
things you you put them some place and
like give them like you you starve them
for three days and then give them one
chicken wing and see what happens oh
like my sister my sister's obsessed with
big brother and I asked her like okay
like how do they make that work and she
was like oh like she's like like when
you're in the in the house like the
dwelling whatever it is like there's no
TV there's nothing to distract you from
like the other people around you from
these people yeah and like you have to
you have to to interact and it causes
controversy and I'm like man why don't
they just like beat the hell out of each
other like like why doesn't one guy just
like beat the hell out of another guy
and she was like because people there
there's people all over the place she's
like well you security going through the
Halles exactly you know what like
sometimes it's worth it like I saw that
there was a show all right I'm I'm gonna
test this Theory I'm gonna fund it
YouTube comic book channels in a house
for a month with one chicken wing we'll
see what happens oh [__] man it's not
happening dude that chicken Wing's gonna
get eaten by me I'm G to tell you right
now
wake up like one o' in the
morning I'm already putting bets on mine
and Amy D's Alliance I've never met her
never I just feel like feel like it'll
link up you guys would be good to go you
two would be have everybody here played
The Simpsons arcade game oh yeah man
we're like you R around take the
characters you put them together and
they do a combo move you and Amy D and
be the Bart and Lisa move where you hold
hands and you just yell
everybody I I could see myself getting
kicked out of the house day one cuz I'd
probably just walk around the whole
house just interrupting everyone as they
try and talk you know yeah I mean it's
just like like hey s like how you doing
hey guys what's going on hey what's up
it's me Vinny by what are you doing get
the [__] out of here you know what I
would like you know what I would all
right I would see that the the comic
book YouTubers in a house somewhere um
so who like go down the list ask the
chat who are we missing from the house
well now here's the kicker though here's
the truth the truth is unless it was
staged like issues the comic book
YouTuber house would just turn into all
of us reading comic books and not
talking we weren't allowed to have comic
books that would be the end of it then
be the end sit and talk about Comics be
great it just be Rob going like so
here's what happened guys and every
going yeah I
know all of us around just hey guys I'm
gonna sit down I'm gonna explain the
Xmen spider
yeah that would divide into people that
prefer the X men and people who prefer
the Avengers and we would recreate
Avengers versus X-men then the Phoenix
would come into existence CU we're that
Bor that much rage oh my God all you
have to do is just say Mayday Parker
thoughts they completely destroy
everybody and I'd be over in the corner
being like does anybody like the Justice
League
exactly God I could I could imagine that
like we would have comic Drake comic
book girl 19's getting mentioned well
she'd be interesting she'd be in her
Corner doing her own thing
everyone [__] [__] robot that she
has on her damn Grace uh whatever Grace
no wait wait hold on you guys saying
comic book cast do you mean all of comic
book cast because that
like I say just like Joel and
armman comic Island but no like like
that would like I could see like they if
they adverti that it would just descend
into total Madness because it it would
be like people just like like totally
losing their sanity is what it would
what it would look like like like like
eventually like the like the season
finale like the series finale would be
like like f said like Avengers versus
X-men and then like a papier-mâché
Phoenix comes down from the ceiling and
it's like explodes into pieces and then
we're all like I've got the Phoenix our
artistic sides comes
out it was the corner making the Phoenix
for the last
month suddenly suddenly one of us
becomes a quick change artist strips off
a clothes and into a spandex phix out I
told you spandex works
you can't put leather underneath
clothing then you just look bulky yeah I
mean is to to bring this whole thing
full circle yes isn't that the purpose
of comic book costumes that's why it
started as spandex it was to be kept
underneath other clothing yeah so yeah
yeah like Batman and armor Superman and
armor Flash and armor doesn't make sense
because it doesn't fit underneath
everything anymore well it's not like
Superman went and was like Hey Oh my God
like like Lois Lane's fall yeah Lis
Lane's falling from a building and she's
only got like 2 seconds before before I
can save her like I better like take off
my clothes and put on my Superman
costume and then go fly he's like man
[__] that noise literally does that and
the latest episode of the show somebody
was like about to die or get captured or
something and he's at home in his
civvies and he managed to change
costumes and be there in a second oh
yeah he moves at the speed of light
though like he can get away with
that super to be fair they can't go
about wearing their costumes because
like if they were Le because they'd have
to wear like a trench coat and they just
end up going about like
hey just run up on somebody oh [__] I
was in my
costume I mean like I will say I that's
one prop I will give to Amazing
Spider-Man the movie the first one where
he didn't immediately make a
$200,000 like ribbed spand like not
spandex like whatever that like pleather
outfit that like Toby McGuire had where
he's like oh I'll just draw Spider-Man
perfectly and then I'll come up with
this with this like really expensive
clearly costume that I made in my house
like you didn't do that but like Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man like he had like a
hoodie and like a little Spider-Man mask
like that worked that's funny like
that's cool but then he of course had
like the really expensive costume after
that so like you that's my problem
according to the the Andrew Garfield one
and this is what I've always found funny
about all those Spider-Man movies and we
should probably start closing it up
after this um but as far as I can
remember aren't they all like he orders
like Lou suits and stuff like that he
orders like full body suits and and
every time he does it I'm just thinking
like as soon as somebody saw their their
designed suit now altered in a SP man
outfit wouldn't orders yeah who the hell
order this because we don't sell that
many of these things yeah oh yeah or or
how do we get a hold of him for a
product placement I'm yeah exactly oh
and see here would be the funny thing
look like a NASCAR driver just tied
and here here would be the funny thing
like if all of us were living in a house
like in this reality show like like
inevitably like inevitably like we would
order pizza and like the pizza guy would
show up and like Benny's gonna answer
the door wearing like the Nightwing
outfit and it's like what's going on and
like can I
say the door dress as Harley Quinn I did
answer the door dress as flash on can I
just say uh fast you brought up King Of
The Nerds isn't it amazing the level the
the change between seasons one two and
three with how much Little Caesars has
just enveloped that show where like it
went from a sponsor like hey guys let's
go get a snack oh look it's Little
Caesar's hot and ready pizza only $5 of
pizza to the most recent episode that I
saw which I watch every once in a while
will be um you win like you've won the
challenge you get your own hot and ready
pizza from Little Caesars and then we
spent a like like a a significant amount
of show where they just talk about it
they talk about the pizza they're eating
from Little Caesars that was made seven
hours ago and just been waiting for
someone to get that's like how sh was
amazing amazing I can't believe the
exact they measured where those
pepperonis needed to go it was it's math
it's Pizza math oh dude that shit's a
science man like you can't just you
can't half ass it man you got to be
precise what you do is you make all your
pizzas like a baker at five o'clock in
the morning and
then people order them you just throw
them in the microwave and then give it
to them little business this is why I'd
be crap on King of the NS because I
don't actually like pizza that much give
me
little I just feel like it's bread with
tomato and Pizza on it like like tomato
and cheese on it that's all it is this
is from this is from uh the group that
invent like your your your country
invaded blood sausage is that
correct I'm Scottish so okay
fair country hagus yeah hagus and is red
well I guess it can't be comp as
complicated as like a cardiovascular
system that you boil but you know yeah
isn't isn't haggus just like a bunch of
[__] crammed into like a sheep stomach
or something like that it's not a bunch
of [__] it's it's it's it's like spices
like time specific [__] we don't know
what it is guys I I think I think we the
tangent wait a minute wait a minute I
want to hear I want to hear what haggus
is what's okay explain haggus we explain
haggus you after this we're got to start
closing up the show ha we can talk about
haggas later anybody in the show wants
to know what haggus is called the wi we
have have more people in the chat right
now than we've ever had on an episode of
the weekly poll and we are talking about
sheep sheep's stomach B
if we're gonna keep going perhaps we
should talk Comics
I'm Squirrel Girl anyone been reading it
squ girl you know you know what the
funniest part about this is we brought
on uh nerdsync talked Comics the whole
time closed out with the comic
discussion we brought a comic book cast
we talked Comics latest news we brought
an ARS talked Comics latest news we
bring in Fon we're talking about his
hair About Forever 21 about old 9s TV
shows in
hag don't forget about and the kicker to
this whole thing is and this is what I
find funny is f even said he watched a
couple of the previous episodes to be
prepared for what he was going to get
did his homework see look see look like
people people in the chat are asking for
haggus explain they want Haus expain
that's a
video your favorite why are we talking
about f i i want to formally apologize
on behalf of myself Robin S for you
entering into the weirdest episode of
the weekly poll I think we've ever done
true it's okay I attract weirdness it's
probably my and see like okay this is
why the chat cracks me up because it
starts out like like I want to hear what
haggas like I want to hear haggas
explain and so people like get explained
and then it just like starts
transforming it takes on a life of its
own and people the chat turn something
else sheep stomach explained Benny's
hair is better my hair is no that's
exactly what my hair is going to turn
into fou hair although I'll probably
keep my dark locks I don't I don't I
don't know how it look as over the Chad
just transforms on its own it takes on a
life of its own it's
crazy so guys as usual thank you for
joining
[Laughter]
us oh man I love it when you guys
interrupt me but that had to be the
weirdest Interruption ever get
explain all right oh all right guys uh
as usual you guys know who we are this
is f he is from it super effective he
brings you history of videos where he
goes over the history of characters and
he brings you his opinions on things
like sexuality and com and he brings you
a lot of really interesting stuff and
it's a lot of stuff that we've learned a
lot from ourselves um he and he's a part
of the weekly pool website team which is
by the way the weekly pool.net where you
can go and see his videos with all of
our videos and chat with all of us on
the forums bring all of these
discussions go over to the forums and
let's just see hagas explain on on the
comics explained form preferably because
uh hagas storian I don't know what I'm
going to do with that I mean I don't I
mean I don't know how you explain how
like hag is the stuff in a sheep's
stomach like you just explain the recipe
that's okay stop with the ha stop with
hack is why run it up it tastes better
than people think I interested I would
like yeah I've never had we don't have
any Scottish restaurants the closest
thing I got is an Irish place it's next
door but that's you know and by close
Irish people just Scottish people that
could swim I mean oh wow you pissed off
a few people in the chat
all like I I I asked I asked that once
like I asked an English guy I was like I
was like why do you got Benny left left
I was like I was like why do why do like
English people hate hate like French
people so much and he was like because
they're French I was like okay I guess
that's reason enough do they hate French
people that's yeah like like this one
like a a guy married one gu what is no
no no like like people from England not
American people no not Americans okay
okay so okay so so give me the rundown
on haggus like give me an explanation ha
you buy it in a shop and it tastes good
that's all I know oh really all this
build up and you don't slay the Sheep
yourself no that is blowing my
mind all right guys here I I want to
give you haggus explain real quick I
just pulled it up on the wiki haggus is
a Savory pudding containing a sheep's
pluck which is their heart liver and
lungs minced with onion oatmeal suit
spices salt and mixed with stock
traditionally encased in the animal's
stomach and nowadays is often nowadays
it often has a artificial casing
according to the 2001 English edition of
something I cannot pronounce to save my
life although his description is not
immediately appealing haggus is an
excellent nutty haggus has an excellent
nutty texture and deliciously Savory
flavor well said is that it
I any of you at a convention I'll just
come along with haggus that'll be does
that even travel well can you do that
I'll make it travel well if it knows
what it's good for if it knows what good
people wondering black pudding commonly
known as blood pudding is a type of
blood sausage typically eaten in Britain
Ireland Sweden Estonia and lataria yeah
lataria by the way if you go to the
weekly pool.net and you go to our
general chat there is already a thread
called hag as
explained give your recipes I got to
check this
out so why you checked it out let me
close this out all right guys so f is a
part of the weekly pool team he is he
does not join us often on the podcast
but he is always welcome back f as weird
as this was it had to be one of our
better episodes
I okay um but overall you guys need to
go check us out at the weekly pool.net
um next week we will be here on Rob's
Channel still we will be for the
following couple of weeks afterwards but
we will be moving over to a live stream
service soon and once we get it
corrected this podcast will be located
on iTunes and SoundCloud as usual I'm
Benny the comic storian that is Sal TV
little house that is Rob from Comics
explain that is f from its super
effective another great Channel you guys
need to go check out and that's it I've
done the closing you guys can talk Haas
all freaking night whatever
drop the mic let F do it you can you can
close us out man yeah you want to close
it out F to play us
out
what all right bye
guys oh what what I love how everyone
called that Dr Doom larian haggus sounds
awesome Army are we are we still so all
right guys so go check us out at the
weekly pool.net if you want to continue
this conversation or any other
conversations go to the forums sign up
chat with us we're all checking our
forms f is the only one who's been slow
and I will take blame for that I didn't
tell fa the website was live so you have
over a hundred people registered in the
forums right now yeah and we've
literally only been line for like three
days and we've done bare minimal
promotion so if you want to chat about
your comic books or if you want to
submit articles to our comic book
entertainment threads send them over to
uh saltv house.com Rob at marvel.com or
comic story gmail.com because I'm too
cheap to get my own email address they
all go to me just email me
t.com we are looking for contributors
we're looking for form moderators
anything just send us an email if you
want to be a part of the website we are
there's a lot of stuff coming down the
pipeline guys it is officially live f is
a humongous fan of it he spends all day
and night looking at
it endorsed by
F you know the podcast I found out about
an no the website I found out about an
hour ago yeah for the you found out it
was live an hour ago but you did agree
to be a part of it in December so it was
even
November I don't want people to be like
did they just add F and not even tell
[Laughter]
them he'll figure it out we should just
do that we should just add like people
like compa girl 19 just throw them B
somebody you know you agree to this
you're part of the group oh I didn't
realize yeah no you did be the podcast
Kevin on the show Now Kevin Smith on the
show all right guys so that's it I uh
Rob why don't you play us out and end
the podcast here uh yeah yeah play us
out like I don't know
means to end the
show thanks for coming to the weekly
pool okay anyway uh yeah we're gonna
bring this podcast to guys God
sake before it gets any worse like we
got to end it we'll catch you guys
later